welcome back earth day is coming up and
we stop by subaru of las vegas the
sponsors of this next segment to see how
they continue to make our planet a more
sustainable and livable place take a
look
[Music]
hey so we're here at subaru of las vegas
with our friend burton hughes burton how
are you i am blessed just like you are
jillian well thank you for having us and
april is a really important month and we
are approaching earth day so let's talk
about what subaru overall as a company
is doing to stay eco-friendly
subaru loves the earth is one of our
pillars it's one of the things that we
really champion and you know since may
of 2004 subaru has been building cars
both of our manufacturing facilities
here in the u.s and in japan
are zero landfill plants and so first
manufacturer to ever do that
so nothing goes to a landfill everything
is converted to electricity or is
recycled and that's kind of just the the
real ethos of the company
and so when it comes to the vehicles
specifically there are some things
implemented to make sure that we are
protecting our earth can you tell us
about some of those things so for years
even before the evs became all the rage
subaru really championed partial zero
emission vehicles that's p zevs and
those that means the air coming out of
the tailpipe is cleaner than what it is
in let's say los angeles and so we've
got that plus we have an all new
electric coming out okay so burton
you're teasing us a little bit with this
electric car what can you tell us about
it the solterra just went into
production we'll start seeing them
arriving here at the dealership right
around the first of june and it is a
true all-wheel drive off-the-road
vehicle uh it's a an suv and i tell you
what i think the world's going to fall
in love with it oh you heard it here
first we're so excited to see that and
let's talk about the dealership we're
inside here it's absolutely beautiful
but you guys have taken a few extra
steps just to maintain that eco-friendly
environment tell us about that well
first off this whole facility is
eco-friendly certified with subaru and
that means the waste management the
efficiency for all the electricity
the water the recycling our community
involvement it was all designed around
some very high standards and so it's a
beautiful place plus we got this really
cool living wall that kind of produces
uh oxygen oh and the dogs love it wow
well burton it's really refreshing too
to hear everything that subaru of las
vegas is doing for the community so how
can us as the community take part in
these initiatives we got some great
things going on julian this month let's
begin with the finley subaru of las
vegas donating ten thousand dollars to
the mayor's fund for las vegas life to
plant 25 park ready trees here in las
vegas and then after april subaru of las
vegas will continue to support this
great cause and plant an additional 10
trees a month throughout the rest of the
year
also findlay subaru las vegas is
collecting pop tabs throughout april to
help encourage more people to recycle
their aluminum cans and help families in
need at the ronald mcdonald house
ronald mcdonald house has a pop tab
program where they collect pop tabs and
work with our local recycler to turn
those tabs into donations for their
families
you can visit subaru of las vegas at
6455 roy hornway or call them at
702-495-2100 and you can always visit
their website subaru las vegas dot com
and they have a special offer 1.9
financing for well-qualified buyers for
up to 48 months on select 2022 models